proxima centauri dieser roten zwerg
stand ist unser nächster stelara nachbar
denn er befindet sich nur in etwa 4,2
lichtjahren von der erde entfernt von
zwei jahren 2016 konnten forschungsteams
einen erdähnlichen planeten dort
aufspüren der proxima centauri in seiner
habitablen zone umkreis proxima centauri
b gehen somit bislang als der ert
nächste exoplaneten doch er ist
möglicherweise nicht der einzige
begleiter von proxima centauri existiert
dort möglicherweise ein zweiter planet
und wenn ja wie können wir uns
vorstellen klicks um science-fiction
nirgends täglich faszinierendes seines
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke
denn nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen bei dem neuen
proxima centauri c könnte es sich um
eine super einzige welt mit rund 6
erdmassen handeln hat unser nächster
nachbar der rote zwergsterne proxima
centauri neben dem exoplaneten proxima
centauri b tatsächlich einen weiteren
bislang unentdeckten begleiter das legt
zumindest eine aktuelle analyse eines
internationalen astronomie teams nahe
dazu der wissenschaftler mario damals so
wir freuen uns ihnen den ersten blick
auf das zu ermöglichen was wir für einen
neuen planeten kandidaten im orbit von
proxim erhalten
wir haben es proxima c getauft die
fachleute hatten bei ihren beobachtungen
vor allem die leichte hin und her
bewegung des sterns im visier
denn dieses taumeln legt nahe dass er
unter dem gravitative einfluss vom
planeten steht den umkreisen die
experten und expertinnen konnten in
ihren modellen zeigen dass die stern
bewegung selbst dann eine periodische
unregelmäßigkeit aufweist wenn der
einfluss von flers also strahlen
ausbrüchen und dem bekannten planeten
proxima centauri berücksichtigt werden
durch anwendung der sogenannten
radialgeschwindigkeit methode kam das
astronomie team zu der erkenntnis dass
ein gesteinsplanet den roten zwerg stein
umkreisen könnte diese methode eignet
sich sehr gut um planeten zu entdecken
dafür wenn die radial geschwindigkeit
der sterne in bezug zur erde gemessen um
die hypothetischen planeten kreisen
könnten in bestimmten zeitlichen
abständen werden dafür hoch aufgelöste
spektren des sterns aufgenommen denn
durch die zusammen sind sogar eines
sterns und seinen
nicht erzeugenden prozessen entstehen
ganz charakteristische spektren raus
können fachleute dann sogenannte doppler
verschiebungen wenn sich die
geschwindigkeit des stern sehen bezug
zur erde ändert erkennen die wiederum
rückschlüsse auf die mögliche existenz
eines planeten zu lassen weiterhin sind
in die analysen auch messung des harps
spektrografen des la silla
observatoriums eingeflossen so kam das
us promi team also auf den
hypothetischen planeten proxima centauri
b
diese wären den berechnungen zufolge
möglicherweise etwa sechs erdmassen
schwer und somit eine super erde
zudem ist der extrem kalt flüssiges
wasser ist hier wohl nicht zu erwarten
dazu der astrophysiker fabio del sordo
wir schätzen dass die
oberflächentemperatur von proxima
centauri 10 uhr etwa 40 kelvin beträgt
umgerechnet sind das minus 233 grad
celsius die analyse der forscher zeigt
also ganz deutlich
falls proxima centauri tatsächlich
existiert wäre leben auf diesem planeten
wohl nicht möglich und noch mehr konnte
das forschungsteam herausfinden die
umlauf dauer des gesteinsplaneten würde
fünf erdenjahre entsprechen und zwar in
etwa demselben abstand wie der mars die
sonne umkreist bei dem erst 2016
entdeckten planeten proxima centauri b
ist das anders er ist mindestens 1,3 mal
so massereich wie die erde und
vielleicht sogar warm genug dass dort
leben existieren könnte doch warum ist
solch ein schwergewicht wie proxima
centauri c nach seiner entstehung nicht
ins innere des systems gewandert
möglicherweise weil unsere derzeitigen
vorstellungen über die entwicklung von
clayton einfach nicht stimmen
und diese dringend überarbeitet werden
müssen doch bevor die existenz des
hypothetischen proxima centauri c
bewiesen werden kann sind auf jeden fall
noch weitere daten und auswertungen
notwendig auch das verantwortliche
forschungsteam unterstreicht das noch
einmal dazu farben des ordo der nachweis
ist sehr schwierig wir haben uns oft
selbst gefragt ob das ein echter planet
ist aber eines ist sicher selbst wenn
dieser planet nur ein luftschloss ist
sollten wir weiter daran arbeiten ihm
ein festes fundament zu verschaffen
beispielsweise könnte die esa-sonde gaia
dabei helfen mehr details zu der taumel
bewegung vom proxima centauri zu
bekommen zukünftigen teleskope könnten
den potenziellen planeten nach ansicht
der fachleute vielleicht sogar direkt
beobachten
doch das mysteriöse taumeln des stern
proxima
lowry erlaubt auch noch andere
interpretationsmöglichkeiten denn diese
hin und her bewegung könnte nicht nur
durch ein schwergewicht wie proxima
centauri c hervorgerufen werden sondern
auch durch die existenz mehrerer
leichter begleiter dafür spricht auch
die theorie dass sich systeme von vielen
kleinen und felsigen planeten um
massearme sterne bilden auch
informationen die das radioteleskop
observatorium alma geliefert hatte
sprachen bereits dafür dass sich mehrere
planeten in dem proxy x system befinden
neue studie zeigt außerirdisches leben
könnte ganz nahe sein
da geht es nämlich um proxima centauri b
der laut der studie lebensfreundlich ist
hammer anklicken anschauen und also hier
neugier zone sehr gut kulas 1-kanal
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran